we have the New York Times Iowa caucus
results queued up for those that are
here watching live you can see we have
on the screen right here but what do you
notice what do you what do you notice in
their uh default breakout of the uh
candidates I notice our Buddy isn't
there who wants to who wants to say it
yeah no VI on VI is not included in the
New York Times default breakout you have
to then click view all candidates to
bring him up along with Chris Christie I
thought he dropped out ASA Hutchinson
and Ryan Bley yeah Christy did drop out
but he's still on the ballot I don't
even know who Ryan Brinkley is he was
the first person to do the full grassly
this cycle he did all 99 counties and uh
he really he did oh wow is he still
running uh no he's he suspended his
campaign but I think he still has a few
folks going to caucus for him and really
and Hutchinson's been out for a while no
he's still in he's still in he's still
in yeah wow yeah he's uh that's kind of
depressing but you know more power to
him I guess 1% oh is he really Chris
Christie dropped out but I I do love
that uh V is not included in their
default breakout of the of the total
reporting should be interesting to see
what ends up happening because of that
it was the same with CNN and Fox News
yeah apparently what what fox so we did
we did uh a ride along with v today and
he showed me like a screenshot from his
Fox News hit this morning he's like
what's going on guys like what is this
and he pointed at the screen and it just
showed it's a poll it was a poll of who
are you cocking for and they did not
include his name but the weird thing on
CNN is when you clicked uh the link and
went there it the big article was VI's f
I don't understand what was going on I
think if you go to CNN right now and it
probably just show you V I guess that's
it but I suppose the the big news and
the big questions we can start talking
about right now is Donald Trump versus
VI ramaswami this is like the big
subject for the longest time everybody's
kind of wondering how it is that V is
running against Donald Trump but there's
no fighting and so we actually got to
the point where I think it was Dave
Rubin who tweeted that V he I I don't
want to get him wrong but Dave had
something to effect that Trump is
working with or for I'm with I'm sorry V
is working with or for Trump or
something like this yeah that was a big
narrative that was being pushed by uh
the disantis camp for for quite a while
and um you know I think V was smart for
for a long time for not taking shots at
at president Trump and uh he kind of
stayed above the frey in that fight uh
but president Trump certainly doesn't
enjoy when people use his face or name
for for you know Financial purposes and
uh those t-shirts that V was pushing
with the safe Trump vote V mess Mage I
think that was a little um I think that
upset a few people including president
Trump and rightfully so president Trump
has never liked when people use his name
he even sued little MC Miller over the
song Donald Trump and so uh I think that
was a a rookie mistake made by V and it
happened at an inopportune time for the
guy yeah so this is the story I just
Google searched the image India West is
the source I don't know what they are
but this image is real and it's V with a
group of young men and they're wearing
shirts that say save Trump vote V look
man I like v he's a he's a good dude
he's a smart guy he's a hardworking guy
but this is this was a mistake this was
a big mistake I understand the the the
message like okay Trump's his life is at
risk if the Deep State really wants him
to not be president that they'll stop at
nothing I get that but like to to rely
on that as a campaign message is a
little lame like you got to be the best
candidate not like oh that other guy's a
problem so vote for me instead that just
doesn't fly it doesn't it doesn't
sustain my opinion show me why you're I
mean look V has a great thing going as
if the Deep state does really stop at
nothing and and go after Trump and let's
not even explain like the worst that
could happen we're going to be happy
that it's not just Nikki Haley waiting
in in in the in the bleachers yep so
make around that was the argument that I
overheard as he's doing radio interviews
all day uh with uh Alex Jones Bonino he
was like the argument I couldn't hear
Alex Jones or bino but you could tell
they were like Trump's going after you
why would you run with this stupid shirt
and his argument was Alex Jones you just
did 20 minutes we just did 20 minutes
together on how they're going to
assassinate Trump oh GE so then what
happens next and Bonino you just did a
whole interview where you and Tucker
talk about assassination of trump for 30
straight minutes yep so what do you what
do you think's going to happen next game
theory that out for me so I think that's
I I I don't think that's smart I don't
think that t-shirt's smart but that's
the I think the Strate the thought
process the t-shirt is cringy sure but I
thought Trump's response could have been
better think he could have been a lot
smarter about this situation his
statement today uh made more sense but
he could have reached out to Vivic he
could have uh sent out a message saying
hey I don't need saving thank you uh
without kind of uh dividing a lot of
people as of course uh you know Don Jr
was here just a couple days ago and he
talked about how we don't have a bench
and this kind of infighting I don't
think is is productive and I think it
could have been handled totally
different in my opinion well it is
politics and V is running for president
against against Trump and he has stayed
out of uh you know kind of the Firing
Lane uh the entire cycle so far true and
this was really his first hi Hiccup and
mistake I think of the campaign and uh
you know president Trump is a fighter by
nature and he typically doesn't hold
back saying things that are on his mind
and uh that was probably the first thing
that came to his mind yesterday and so
he put it out and you know look I think
a lot of us do like v a lot of us do
think he has a future in the movement
and a future in the party I don't think
it's uh this year uh but I do think you
know he's a young guy and uh when we're
talking looking at our bench down the
future I think Ronda santis stepped on a
landmine this cycle and has no future
after this I think a lot of people saw
his response and and I think some people
took offense to it because they kind of
saw it as punching down and and they saw
it as infighting and and and to me
that's how just some people reacted to
it but um you know again it's a crazy
situation and um a lot of people want it
handle handled differ I think the only
smart I think the only smart move here
quite frankly is for Trump to release a
save vake shirt that would have been
yeah that would have been a that would
have been funny that would been
hilarious good that is good and' be like
I got you save a from himself well
I I want to make a point piggybacking
off of what you said Alex um with Dan
santis and the fact that he stepped on a
land mine here it's just fascinating me
because yeah this is the first time I
have ever felt that I liked a politician
and hated their campaign it's a very
strange phenomena no I mean I don't even
like the guy anymore you don't like him
anymore at all sorry but finish your
point yeah no well my point was
basically just that and I I I've said
this on the show before I think that if
Trump and DeSantis are both strong
that's great for the United States of
America I want both of those men to be
as successful as possible and then going
up against each other in the cycle and
Des santis deciding to run has turned
out to be a complete disaster for him in
his campaign and he ended up basically
jumping head first into the politician
wood chipper that is Donald Trump I
believe to borrow the the phrasing from
Aron mckintyre and so there's a lot that
DeSantis has done that I think is
fantastic I would like to to see him
have a strong future in politics but
unfortunately I think his campaign has
been a disaster and I also say that as
someone who's had friends work for him
people who I like I think the people
making decisions foris are really not uh
trustworthy and I think they're making
bad calls and this is the moment that I
would like to uh formerly apologize to
Will Chamberlain and Jordan L and Jordan
Chamberlain good they're friends of ours
they're good friends of mine a good guy
and I want to apologize because on on
the show last week I said that they were
living in Maryland while working for
Ronda santis and that was not true and
so will I'm really sorry about that I
didn't I didn't know I made a mistake I
read these articles I I assumed you were
still in the area because you had been
on the show earlier but they were
actually living in Florida at the time
when they were working for so seriously
sorry about that guys I mean and when
Will's the one of the people I'm
thinking of Will's the man like I I
really like that guy yeah I don't know
how you get rid of will who's actually a
smart guy competent guy and then keep
some of these other dumpster fires
around so uh yep and and and this is
what I said D will if they put him in
charge Des sandz would be pulling way
higher he could be he could have the
campaign that V is having V made this I
think this is a mistake V made but I
still think he's doing really well but I
got to tell you when I mentioned to you
earlier I don't even like Ron anymore I
got to be
honest Laura lmer put out that video
where she confronts him and you know
it's it is I don't know how you describe
it but it is shocking to be confronted
by Laura lommer if you're if you're some
of these people right but a question
that someone asked and she also asked
was why are you in Iowa when your state
is is in a state of emergency and and I
was like whoa I I didn't even realize I
looked it up sure enough there's
flooding and a disaster going on in
Florida and not only did he come out
here but correct me if I'm wrong I'm
hearing that he brought out his gator
his Governor's gorial staff as well yes
and I was like whoa whoa whoa dude dude
this is this is not okay okay he he
would have earned way more political
points by saying I'm not going to be
able to to to campaign in Iowa
understand why there are people who
depend on me I will never abandon the
people who voted for me people of Iowa
blah blah blah instead he was was like
I'm out he flies in flies out comes here
and then goes to campaign in a blizzard
where all the stores are shut down we
were walking around outside the and like
it wasn't even snowing very hard but the
snow had come overnight and the
restaurants are closed everything's
closed bared under snow for what reason
did he decide to come out here when
people are canceling events he he
actually abandoned his State during a
state of emergency flooding into
disaster to campaign in a state that was
dealing with its own weather I was just
that pissed me off I'm sorry man and
weather that people from Florida have no
idea how they have to deal with Florida
Florida people don't know how to deal
with ice and snow and cold
and what's the gator guy going to do up
here huh as a person yeah that's right
lift your legs when you walk so two
things
one and press down Jo Biden
that but can you lift your legs that
high in Boots like that is the question
it was fun I I have big boots they're
like the big polar Boots the Balenciaga
baffins how big's the heel it's pretty
big oh oh they got they wedges inside
they give me about good four inches you
know can I pull the audience real quick
what do you guys make of a man that well
wears high heels in a campaign
Trail and that's okay it's okay yeah I
got a I got AIT that I got a question
for you guys we're talking in the Green
Room beforehand about um basically the
liberal economic order most powerful
force on Earth most powerful Global
government ever created so if these guys
Viv and Donald Trump are saying like
we're going to we're going to disrupt it
my thought is okay well then your life
is on the line so if you do win the
presidency you're going to have to go
into hiding or govern from like some
secret location and they were like no
that would be like an abandonment I'm
like but if you stay in contact with the
people via internet video be like I have
no choice but to be in a Mountain Base
what do do you guys think that's a good
idea you think it's unnecessary what do
you think going against the liberal
World Order well I mean they're talking
about dismantling the FBI which is
essentially going against the liberal
economic ORD well so let's let's let's
PR a little bit I know there's a lot of
people who are probably uh more General
viewers we've covered this this quite a
bit but the liberal economic order is a
system you can uh that was built after
World War II Ian brings up quite a bit
it's a legitimate thing this is not
conspiracy theory I know the media is
going to try and claim it is it's uh
what is it the CFR the Council on
Foreign Relations they might be involved
it was started in 1949 and uh they were
like this is going to guarantee we don't
have World War III they built American
Le rules-based economy is what they call
it and they build all these American
military bases they use American money
and they've been enforcing it so they're
like these people are like we got to
create a new world order this liberal
economic order is no longer effective we
got to create a new system is where
they've been like the world economic
forum is starting to step in but this
liberal economic order is kind of now
being siphoned into this new world order
that they're trying to this global
banking thing um and Trump has been like
kind was kind of a bull like he kind of
when he when he cancelled the the the
transp specific partnership you could
see that he was not playing that game he
was not going to sell out the United
States thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 p.m. and become a member over at
Tim c.com for uncensored membersonly
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next
time